i would introduce stephen as the host of
ladder with crowder i think i now need
to
introduce him as the former host of
louder with crowder really i should
introduce him
as the former man who is the former host
of ladder with crowder because he's
being completely unpersoned
by youtube by twitter we bring on now
to help us understand all of this
stephen crowder and
half asian lawyer bill richmond that is
the official title i don't want to be
kicked off
for saying that myself bill that is your
official title correct that that is for
now but i
am going to just switch to full asian
just to make sure i stay fully
uncancelable in the future
so be careful because since then some a
knockout game might be coming your way
um thanks for introducing me uh
referring to me as a loser thanks for
that long setup
thank you i appreciate it you're the one
you're generically ethnic
perfect fop thank you
that's true do i by the way am i going
to get a pass the sicilians are one of
the most persecuted people
in the history of the world in this new
racial caste system that's being created
by the intersectional left do i get a do
i get a pass
i don't know because you guys have been
trying to distance yourself from the
moors and the uh
the black history i saw a true romance
you guys have a thing about that the
sicilians are not necessarily
super uh super open armed and loving no
look i still am the host uh
and by the way people can follow me on
crowder bits on youtube and we're always
available you know
on mug club on the blaze the premium
content uh
there but uh yeah it's uh as people may
or may not know it's it's the
adpocalypse
two is the hashtag right now yeah it was
uh was
hard struck uh for something that was
not in violation of any rules it's
it's very clear right now for people who
haven't been following this the episode
in question well two one was we did 15
days to flatten the curve an anniversary
a one year anniversary for 15 days to
flatten the curve i believe i was on
that episode actually
that's right you were on that episode uh
all of the sources are available at
lateralcredit.com
most of them are the world health
organization the cdc and the imperial
college of london by the way we use
their mortality rates we use their
infection rates
and they said you can't talk about this
so that was removed but it wasn't
considered a heart strike so it's very
clear that you simply cannot be
conservative and discuss covid
we know exactly why they're coming after
you because
you had the temerity to to question the
election
and uh because you you a comedian made
offensive jokes that offended the
sensibilities for some people okay
fine let's say let's say that that
youtube
hates everything you have to say about
the election and let's say they hate
your jokes too
fine by me surely youtube
disagrees with a lot of what people say
on their platform surely
youtube finds a lot of things
distasteful on their platform
surely youtube knows what you've said
and thought before
why is this happening now i mean it just
seems so
arbitrary it seems so capricious and are
you hearing anything from them about how
when you're going to get
get your channel restored so to jump
onto that let me let me talk about both
of them so first of all we had twitter
this is where he doesn't want me to talk
and get us in trouble
over the last five weeks five almost six
weeks now we've had four different
instances where twitter has sent a form
email that says
here's the reason why you're off and
it's a specifically
colin blank they send the form
without actually saying what the post is
that was a violation
much less what the reason is even though
their own public statements both the
congress
both in their guidelines have said over
and over we're going to tell you what
the reasons are
now let's fast forward to the youtube
example because remember we're now under
currently a seven day ban on twitter
from being able to say anything from
being able to shed any light
on what youtube is doing right now the
ability to be able to do that is highly
limited except for friends like you who
are allowing us to be able to come out
and talk about this right now so the
reason
that's my word not steven's word so
when we look at what they've given us
today all they have simply said
is here's the video that's a problem
they don't say what specifically about
the video is a problem much less do they
acknowledge
that we had a video immediately before
and an immediate video immediately after
that dealt with the same issues
and in every single instance making sure
to the detail that we were bringing
clear evidence that was still within the
policy
and this is the part that's perhaps the
most sinister about it it's
not a policy that says you need to come
with proof
if you're going to say something
controversial it's you're not even
allowed to say the controversial thing
so we made sure you're not you're not
allowed to provide proof
right our greatest in here was providing
proof this is something that's really
sinister that bill uh
left out was banned from suspended from
twitter
okay for whatever it was how many days i
came back
i posted one tweet between the previous
suspension
and the new suspension yeah the only
tweet that i posted was
twitter testif twitter has stated in
front of congress that they are
transparent
and tell people what violations have
occurred so that they can rectify it
and i posted a screenshot that said you
have violated blank
so twitter then suspended me for
pointing out that twitter is suspending
without reason
so it's not just on youtube you cannot
be conservative have a conservative
opinion on these issues
you can't have a conservative opinion on
transitioning children you cannot have a
conservative opinion
on uh election laws you cannot have a
conservative opinion that values liberty
over
uh safety of a virus with a 99.9
death rate you cannot have those
opinions but now on twitter
you are not allowed to criticize twitter
that's the key that's the key to it
right because i think
if for people who are listening let's
say they're more moderate let's say
they're not quite as conservative as we
are they're slightly to the left of
genghis khan or something like that
surely you can see
the double standard right stephen
crowder
raises questions about the 2020 election
boom he's off he's got to go
stacey abrams and hillary clinton
and on and on and on and on raise
questions about all sorts of elections
stacey abrams to my mind still hasn't
conceded the 2018 gubernatorial election
that's totally fine not only do those
figures get to stay on but all their
supporters who raise these kind of
questions
nor has al gore nor is that yeah nor has
al gore for that matter
so you you know obviously there's a
double standard there you made a joke
that the left finds racially offensive
about black people uh robin d'angelo
goes on
videos and says be less white and then a
whole lot of commentators
upload videos saying yeah you should be
less white yeah we should abolish
whiteness yeah
whiteness is toxic those videos all get
to stay up but
you you make a joke that they find
racially offensive in the other
direction
that so for sure there's a an insane
double standard here
but then you i think you highlight the
real point here which is
these entities youtube and twitter
are going to protect themselves they're
going to do whatever they want and if
you call them out on that
they're going to shut you up too and it
might not even be a political question
it's just about them keeping their power
and let me be clear too i want to be
really clear for people listening
i didn't even question the election i
said we have a broken
voting system that allows people to vote
from non-existent addresses without id
here's proof of these addresses so i
want to be really clear that's well
within their rules
i didn't say the elections and i don't
are they going to go back and cover our
uh remove our election stream uh live i
think i think the reason too that
there's a target look if i were cnn
if i were nbc the last one was nbc uh
you know uh
nbc vox is that nbc universal nbc
universal
uh this one we know that there's been
some pressure from take your pick it
could be turner
it could be uh could be abc disney
look if we were covering for example
today the the chauvin trial or as was
happening yesterday and i'm cnn and i'm
brian stelter i'm anderson cooper i'm
brian williams
and i go hey how are we doing and i see
that this little show you know that
started out of a den
is getting octuple the viewership
i'd want i'd probably want to shut them
down too if i had no confidence in my
abilities and understood that
you know i was a shoe in based on
nepotism so i think that's a component
to it right now we're kind of you know
we have a target because we're bigger
than these other entities and they want
to get their foothold
uh uh right i love this angle because
so often what the left does is they'll
distract you so let's say look over here
look over here and then meanwhile
they're totally upending our culture
you know somewhere else where you're not
paying attention and so we're all
focused on the political component
obviously that's playing a huge role
here
you disagree with the politics of a lot
of people at these companies
but there is also a raw business media
component
which is they are the establishment
media
they are supposed to control the
narrative and big tech plays a huge role
in that now too because
the minute you had social media all of a
sudden conservatives start doing really
really well we blast past the
gatekeepers we start getting our ideas
out there
well that that is hugely as you point
out it's hugely embarrassing
for cnn that stephen crowder with his
with his cameras in his youtube channel
is doing better than they are
so i do see this angle of corporate
media just coming in
and snuffing out the little guy and and
one of the one of the
most sinister from a legal side
standpoint i know we use that word
sinister a lot but it's very true
is think about from an and at a very
basic any trust level which is what
you're seeing good
google facebook other lawsuits that are
going on right now is
you have media companies like nbc
universal disney
other big companies who are viacom who
are telling another media company
youtube and twitter to then go silence a
competitor
third media company that's taking
eyeballs and ears
and all of that is being allowed to
happen right now in this nation while
other things are happening but here's
the other part about it is we're you're
really not just silencing a voice you're
silencing
counter ideas you talked about fans of
yours or audience members who are maybe
in the middle or even on the left
this is a problem for anyone who's ever
had a contrarian view with a government
or an administration if you've ever held
an idea
that would be critical if for example
you don't like kids in cages with
with joe biden i'm sorry uh minimum you
know security prison with joe biden i
don't know what the phrase is we're
supposed to call space camp there we go
border space camp if you don't like
anything about that
the power has been given to the tech
companies to be able to say
whenever they want we're not going to
just
limit what you're saying we're going to
limit the idea of id we're going to
limit the marketplace of ideas
so that there isn't even that
consideration any longer
i want to speak gentlemen not not just
about
what's going on here because obviously i
think we all know intuitively what's
going on but the big tech companies are
stonewalling you
i want to talk about what to do now
because for a long time in the
conservative movement or libertarians
there has been this idea that government
bad corporations good
so we got to stop the government from
infringing on our rights and our free
speech tradition
but you know corporations man they're
great oh yeah they're a private company
start your own youtube start your own
twitter
and that seems to me to be a bunch of
bunk right now
so what's the plan how are you going to
fight back well first off let me address
that and then and then
uh how patientville can get to the plan
look you have to throw that completely
out the window when you have section 230
and you have hundreds of millions of
dollars going directly to the dnc from
five companies that are more powerful
than any empire that's ever existed
right amazon apple google youtube
facebook twitter
so that's now changed because they lobby
and they spend
fortunes to ensure that they get
favorable policy
from those in government and by the way
not just democrats a lot of republicans
too they want a grand stand at one of
these hearings and then all right
that that makes lunch so um it's very
very different now at this point for the
same reason that you know verizon can't
ban you if you say something that's
offensive across your phone they're
treated like public utilities
so it doesn't apply here it's not the
same as a mom and pop store
mom and pop stores don't control the
flow of information through
getting their feet in the door with the
government through lobbying and they
don't enjoy the same protections the
safe harbor that these companies do
with section 230 they need to decide are
they a publisher like the new york times
like washington post
in which case they have the right to
remove opinions uh
such as such as mine which by the way
aren't even a strong pg-13
to be clear we keep this in line with
what could be broadcast on television
it's offensive to people who don't have
a sense of humor but it's not certainly
not vulgar certainly not an r rating
if they want to do that fine then that
means they're liable for what's on their
platform
but right now they're not and that's
under the guise of they don't censor
content
they don't have any control or editorial
guidelines
and that's that's not accurate so people
need to understand
that and uh the libertarians need to to
understand that their argument
you know listen it's just it doesn't
apply it's just like it's just like
saying that if you legalize black tar
heroin the drug cartels will go out of
business they're going to straighten up
and fly right
by the way we're also going to ban guns
so yeah no the black market will go away
it's it's silly
it's it's fairy tales right and actually
you bring up a good point here that
i i do want people to realize you know i
spend a lot of time
reading the fringe of the radical left
and the fringe of the radical right you
know i'm
constantly in these recesses of the
internet and literature
you are basically as mainstream as it
gets
it is it is not like you're some fringe
figure here out here on the right i'm
talking about a guy who rose to fame by
writing about the fact that i
my wife and i did not have sex until we
were married because of my faith
okay that was considered more offensive
than a lot of so let's just be clear
about that what do i believe in i
believe in the first amendment the
second amendment
i'm a cr i'm a christian i'm a family
man and i believe that people should be
able to speak freely even if it's
offensive
i believe in lower taxes and i believe
in a strong national defense
i couldn't be more you know basically
conservatism since this is on
terrestrial radio
this is the shot over the bow if youtube
says
that i cannot go to physical addresses
that don't exist
and show that i'm they are saying to
everyone out there people need to
understand this
if you're a conservative your view is
not welcome
and they should have to deal with that
financially then they should have to
state it publicly
rather than doing it in the shadows so
from a legal perspective michael what
really it gave me summed up is this
we're pro-business but anti-fraud
these tech companies have without a
question created a machine that mines
data from their customers
to be able to better sell ads and that's
what facebook has said in congress
that's what they say in their 10ks when
they're publishing for their
shareholders
that's how this entire business is run
well how do they do that they need
content creators like steven to be able
to
generate a reason why people will come
to the site how to bring
5.4 million subscribers to youtube or
a million plus subscribers on followers
on twitter
so you get all of these people in you
say thank you for bringing them in
now let me redirect them to where the
ads want to go these media companies
these nbc universals the disney's the
viacoms etc
oh well we're actually not going to show
your content anymore
we're not going to any longer show the
things that would allow you to make
money and that's where the fraud part
comes in
consumers are told these platforms are
evenly enforced
and here are the guidelines they are
very clear but in reality they're not
following the guidelines
it's like going into a store and being
told yeah you can come into the store
yes you can spend money and after you
spend the money they go oh actually the
rules say you can't have the product you
just paid for
that's what these folks don't realize is
happening on a daily basis
it's a consumer crisis that is really
even though
largely aimed at conservatives because
they're the ones who are creating the
content
driving the people in and then all of a
sudden those content creators aren't
there anymore
the content itself isn't there anymore
these businesses
have the right to be able to set the
rules but what they don't have a right
to do
is deceive the public into giving their
data into being the product
for these companies and allowing them to
make their billions of dollars
a quarter or a day or a week right and
then take away the content
down the rules that were stated and can
i add one more point to this listen
because he's making the
the legal argument there and i think
it's important i think they need to be
hit where it hurts as far as you know
financially
um but let's be clear when people a lot
of people out there say well if you
don't like it go to a different platform
they have the right you know if it's
offensive
you shouldn't have offensive content on
their platform let me put this into
perspective here okay
an entire episode of ours was removed of
mine was removed
where the most offensive thing that i
said was
the imperial college of london said 2.4
million people would be dead there would
be a three percent mortality rate
and it turns out that the actual
mortality rate is significantly closer
to the normal flu for young healthy
people than three percent that's
scientifically undeniable right
that is removed lil nos being sodomized
by
satan is kid friendly now to be clear
i'm not offended by lil noss being
sodomized by satan i mean i don't know
selling shoes no i don't love it but my
point is i certainly don't think that
should be
chill child friendly yeah ours is
removed and that's available for
eight-year-olds
so this is what happens too this is the
attempt to when we're talking about sort
of orwellian the attempt to mold
people's point of view you go to youtube
to let's say
learn how to fix a carburetor or maybe
learn how to
do uh you know do something with an
ar-15 build at home right this is
something that's legal
and instead you find yourself guided to
advertisements
for a medical virtual visit with hormone
blockers for your six-year-old
this is trying to guide perspectives and
ban
perspectives and they are banning
traditionalist conservative
uh christian perspectives in favor of uh
you know sodomy with satan which listen
creative license
but but what do you really feel i mean
what's the no you've identified the
stakes
so well here because i just think for
such a long time
we were so blinded by the idea that this
battle over pc
and wokeness or whatever is purely about
free speech
versus censorship when really as you
describe very well
it's a battle between competing sets of
standards
so stephen crowder reads some statistics
that is
that is offensive you can't do that but
twerking in in satan's face if you're
little nast little nast x uh totally
totally fine
uh we we've gotta leave it there
gentlemen you can still find
steven crowder at crowder bits on
youtube they can't find you on twitter
though right
not right now for i don't know how long
that remains to be seen either but also
you know they can always join uh mug
club lightweight.com we have a promo
code fight like hell
and people get 20 off so that's the best
place for people to support us
that's the probably the safest spot
right now until some web servers or
something try to kick you off
that is where you can find them that is
where you should find them go find
stephen crowder over at mug club
go find the formerly half asian lawyer
bill and now the fully asian lawyer bill
i think
by the way guys if this culture keeps up
you will need to become the 150
asian lawyer bill just to protect
against the new the new
racial caste system gentlemen uh really
glad you're fighting back on this and i
encourage everybody to go
go support that fight